and now Ohio police officer is getting
national attention for how he handled a
tense situation that could easily have
turned deadly
dramatic body camera video shows the
officer stopping two boys who he thought
had a gun but instead of using force he
used the power of his words Dean
Reynolds spoke to the officer and one of
the boys come on one with the address of
your emergency I don't know if it's a
real gun ma'am but Columbus police
officer Peter casue CHEO responded but
had no idea 11 year-old j-kwon soul was
holding a BB gun as he pulled up with
his service revolver drawn when j-kwon
dropped the BB gun and it shattered on
the sidewalk officer casue CHEO gave him
an earful you can't do that dude in
today's world
what's it is that thing looks real bro
you should be sorry and you should be
scared we stopped by the 5th district
station house to speak with officer
Kazuki oh why were you so insistent on
making the point to him because we are
seeing on a national level that there
are kids with you know BB guns and
and/or other toy guns that are very
realistic-looking the officer can't
discern in that split-second in that
millisecond well that's a real firearm
or not in 2016 13 year old Tyree King
was shot to death by a Columbus police
officer as he held on to a BB gun and 12
year-old Tamir rice was shot dead by a
Cleveland officer who mistook his pellet
gun for the real thing
kikuchiyo works one of the toughest
neighborhoods in Columbus this thing
could have turned oh yeah very bad
absolutely we also spoke to Jake wons
mother
Talisa I wouldn't let the officer know
that I am very very happy and blessed
that he did not shoot myself or what he
have done officer kikuchiyo told us he
feels the same way for CBS this morning
Dean Reynolds Columbus we need more
officers like that that officer gave
those kids a benefit of the doubt and
especially in today's climbs that
today's climate makes that extraordinary
what he did and explain explain didn't
just yes
Beryl with the force of boy Mortimer
thank you sir